[Alkış]
Ben Almanya doğumlu 58 yaşında 3 çocuk
annesi bir girişimciyim ve sıkı
diyebileceğim de bir sivil toplum
örgütçüsüyüm
şöyle anlatmaya başlayın ilk olmaz
kelimesi benim hayatımı da çok etkileyen
ilkokul 4 sınıfın sonunda girdiğim
olgunluk sınavında aldığım başarılı bir
dereceydi Almanya'da en iyi not birdir
en kötü not altıdır Ben de 2 almıştım ve
4 sınıftan sonra Yollar ayrılıyor okul
sisteminde 5 yıllık genel okul halkçule
dedikleri 6 yıllık ortaokul ve sonra 9
yıllık Günlüğü az yoğun bugün nazium'un
sonunda da abi olgunluk sınavı veriliyor
ve oradan doğrudan üniversiteye
gidiyorsunuz Her neyse ben bu
İlkokulunun
müdür annemi çağırdı ve dedi ki yani
Şafak başarıları ve çalışkan bir öğrenci
ve Notu da iyi ama önce bir sene
ortaokul genel okula gitsin sonra bir
sene ortaokula devam etsin dokuz sonra
da 9 yıllık liseye gider annem olmaz
dedi
Benim kızımın notu Diğer arkadaşlara
kadar iyi ve 9 yıllık
gülnazyuma ben gittim 1983 senesinde 101
yıllık okul tarihimizden mezun olan ilk
Türk çocuğuydum
[Alkış]
Tabii hayatta insanlar farklı acılar
yaşayabiliyor Ben 12 yaşında annemi
kaybettim babam 46 yaşında dul kaldı
benden bir yaş Küçükte kardeşim vardı
babam haliyle yeniden evlendi ve yeniden
böyle bir olmaz
olayıyla karşılaştık
babamın yapacağı ikinci evlilikte anne
olmaz dediler ama benim annem muhteşem
bir anne olur rahmet eylesin onu da
bazen ebeveynlerimiz de olmaz derler ya
kulak asmak gerekiyor öztürkçe Ben
ailemin hiç Tasvip etmediği bir evlilik
yaptım 7 sene sonunda iki küçük
Çocuğumla ve Bir Hayli banka borcundan
ayrıldım kayseri'deydim Ve ama bu beni
yıldırmadı yani hayat devam edecek dedim
ve hayatıma devam ettirdim ama iş
ararken Kayseri'de son bir olumsuzlukla
daha karşılaştım o da Ha Bakım Merkezi
bir Almanca tercümanı arıyormuş
hemen İŞKUR'dan aldım telefonu ilgili
kişiyi aradım kendimi tanıttım
karşımdakine sordum Evet ne diyorsunuz
olmaz dedi Biz erkek tercüman arıyoruz
bu sefer kendimi pazarlamaya başladım
ama Bakın beni işe alırsanız ileride
İngilizce Fransızca çevirilerinizi de
yaparım çünkü ben İngilizce Fransızcada
Biliyorum ve bilgisayara bunları kendim
aktarırım dedim Olmaz dedi Bence Bir
Büyük Bir Hayal kırıklığıyla daha
görüşmeye gidilmemiş bile olarak oturdum
ve bekledim 3 ay sonra yine Hava Bakım
merkezinde Bir Amerikan şirketinde idari
müdür olarak işe başladım
[Alkış]
içinde Talih yüzüme güldü Ben hava
ikmalde ikinci eşimle tanıştım
Evet yani hani birçok kişi de gene dedi
Yani iki çocuklu dul
evlenmemiş bir bekar adamla olmaz oldu
Çok şükür 28 senedir evliyim ayrı adamla
[Alkış]
ve biz sonra eşimle bir şirket kurduk
şimdi şirketin ismini bir kere
söyleyeceğim reklam olmasın diye Çünkü
şirketin isminin manasını bana çok soran
oluyor nefes Seyit Efe Semiha
isimlerinden isim babası da eşimdir bir
akronim bir şirket ismi
biz 1997'de şirketimizi kurduk o
zamanlar Türk halı ve kilimleri
topluyorduk eşimle
bugüne bugün bu şirketimiz bakın 26
yaşında bir küçük ve orta boy ölçekli
bir işletme için iyi bir yaştır Türk
şirketlerine göre
halı kilim işini şirketi Onun için
kurduk Çünkü Evimizde bir odaya Sadece
bu halı kilimlere tahsis etmek zorunda
yaptık ve ilk ihracatımızı Amerika'ya
yaptık
buradan
sanayide birkaç iş baktım ben
amerikalılardan bu arada
işin bitmişti F16 projesi Tazminatımı
aldım ve sanayide iş bakıyorum bir
sandalye projesi geldi bana bir Alman
İtalyan ortaklı şirketten sandalye
modelini gönderdiler üstünde ufak tefek
değişiklikler yaptık
girin dediler Kayseri'de İnanın bana
aynı sandalyeye 3 farklı firma 3 farklı
fiyat verdi
italyanlara bildirdiğimde dediler ki ben
ne yapıyorsunuz Biz bu fiyata bu
sandalyeleri satıyoruz bırakın üretmeyi
veya satın almayı siz oturun sizin
şirketiniz olsaydı Veya siz üretseydiniz
bunu kaça mal ederdiniz diye sordular
Biz eşimle Oturduk hesapladık işte
sandalyenin sırtı bu kadar oturağa bu
kadar ayakla metal ayakları da bu kadar
bunun nakliyesi de bu kadar da kar
isteriz diye Onlara bir teklif sunduk
bir hafta geçti cevap yok 2 hafta cevap
yok 3 hafta bir akşam vakti telefonum
çaldı
bir ses sinyala dedi Yani işi aldık
Meğer Biz Çin'deki üretim fiyatından
daha Ucuz bir fiyat Vermişiz
peki dedim ama adama bizim yani üretim
tesisimiz yok Biz nasıl olacakmış Biz
sizi öğretiriz bunu dediler ve gerçekten
elimizden tuttular Biz ağaç işlerinde
Demirciler sitesinde 200 metrekare bir
yerde 6-7 işçiyle işe başladık öyle bir
yer ki yani bir tırın malını yüklemeden
öbür tırın ham maddesini içeri
alamıyorduk veya ben burada oturuyorum
masada arkadaşımla konuşuyorum 5 metre
İlerideki döşemeci benim arkadaşımla
olan muhabbetimi dinliyordu Öyle ilginç
oldu ki ve İtalya'ya sandalye ihraç
ediyoruz yani sandalye oturağında ihraç
ediyoruz İtalya'daki Ekonomi Gazetesi
bizden bahsetti Yarım sayfa tabii böyle
bir popüleritede kazanmaya başlayınca
Türkiye'de de duyulmaya başladık Ve ben
2003 yılında ilk yörenin başarılı iş
kadını ödülünü aldım
sonra 2006 senesinde de
yine bana göre en prestijli ödüllerimden
biriydi
milliprodüktivite merkezinden bir ödüle
layık görüldüm ama onu size Kısaca
anlatayım
asistanım telefonu bağladı sizi birisi
arıyor ödül mödül bir şey diyor Dedi
konuştum beyefendi ile size diyor ödül
takdim etmek istiyoruz yılın başarılı iş
kadını olarak ben içimden diyorum ki Aa
olmaz olmaz tabii tabii diyorum
beyefendi anladı herhalde pek ciddiye
almadığımı hanımefendi dedi Biz bu ödülü
sizden önce Güler sevenciye verdik dedi
Tamam dedim Siz verin bana telefonunuzu
ve isminizi ben size dönüş yapayım
kontrol edeceğim ya biri Benimle dalga
mı geçiyor Yoksa gerçekten mi öyle
aradım telefonu beyefendiye istedim
gerçekten milli prodüktivite Merkezi
bana ödül verecekmiş Neyse iki senede
iki hafta sonra gittim ödülümü aldım
Böylece bir anım vardı
bugün bu şirketimiz
şirketimde yaklaşık 60 kişi çalışıyor
4-5 tane de çırağımız var
kadınlarımız da var
İnşallah bu ayın sonunda da organize
sanayiye bölgesine geri taşınacağız
kendi yerimize
ama sizin tek başınıza bir kadın olarak
başarılı olmanız yetmiyor zaten
Kayseri'de herhalde
bir elin
beş parmağa kadar kadınız
bu sefer Tabii daha farklı şeyleri de
giriyorsunuz sivil toplum örgütlerine
giriyorsunuz
Odalar Borsalar birliğinden davet
ediliyorsunuz Ben 2006 senesinin sonunda
Avrupa Birliği iş kadınları ağına top
tarafından atandım Türkiye'yi temsilcisi
olarak ve oradaki çalışmalarımızın
sonucunda Mayıs 2007'de Biz bir anket
çalışması yaptık Odalar Borsalar
birliğinde 365 oda ve borsa
üyedir otoban kadınların durumlarını
ölçelim diye kaç kadın var
kaç kadın ortaklı şirketler var
odalardaki çalışan kadınların ve
sonradan Ben 2007 Eylül ayında bu
Anketin sonucunu bir durum raporu olarak
Avrupa Birliği karma istişare komitesini
Sapanca'da sundum Bu da çok gurur
duyduğum bir eylemdir ama
[Alkış]
ama
başlığını şöyle atmıştım rapordan
Türkiye'de kadın girişimci 2007 durum
raporu ve Atatürk'ün şu sözüyle
başlamıştım rapora toplumdaki
başarısızlığın nedeni kadınlarımıza
karşı gösterdiğimiz ihmal ve kusurdan
doğmaktadır
[Alkış]
Tabi ben bu aynı zamanda anons edildi
Ekonomik İşbirliği Teşkilatı 10 ülkenin
üye olduğu Ekonomik İşbirliği
teşkilatının Odalar birliğinin kadın
girişimci kurulunda Türkiye
temsilcisiyim bir toplantıdan bir
toplantıya bir rapor yazıyorum öbürü
başlıyor sürekli böyle gittiler geldiler
her şeyler kocam şu meşhur cümleye
söyleyiverdi
karı memleketi Ben şirketi kurtarıyorum
bu yanda bir de tabii ki üç çocuk
büyüttüm ve onlar birbirlerini
büyüttüler
2013 yılında Biz kadın işbirliğini
geliştirme Derneğini kurduk birkaç
girişimci kökenli arkadaş ve o
zamanlarda daha farklı kadın
çalışmalarına girdim O zaman bana kadar
hep kadın girişimcilikle ilgili
Ticaretle ilgili konular vardı ama
sonraki derde farklı kadınlarla
karşılaştık sıkıntı çeken kadınlar
[Müzik]
sermaye arayan kadınlar ve biz o zaman
da bu sefer daha farklı kadın
çalışmalarına bakınca
mertlerin all right Amerikan Dış işler
bakanlığıydı o zamanlar
şu sözünü Ben kendime nasıl diyeyim bir
yol çizgisi edindim
ve Mesela ben şu playing
yani Türkçesi kadına destek olmayan
kadınlar için cehennemde özel bir yer
vardır ama
[Alkış]
ama size şunu söyleyeyim bana göre
erkekler için de özel bir yer var
[Alkış]
sizi Hayatta hiçbir şey durduramıyor
Eğer bu sivil toplum aşkı içinde
yaşıyorsa yani
topluma faydalı olmalıyım ben bir şeyler
yapmalıyım diğer kadınlara da yardım
etmeliyim derseniz farklı şeyleri de
giriyorsunuz
Aslında Talas'ta eski tescilli bir ev
aldık
bu sefer talaslan'da ilgilenmeye
başladım yani kültürel mirası da korumak
gerekiyor Siz tek başınıza almışsınız
bir yer restore etmişsiniz o yetmiyor bu
sefer Talas tanıtım yardım sosyal yardım
dayanışma ve Sosyal Yardımlaşma
derneğine de Üye oldum şu anda orada da
Başkan yardımcısıyım Bir de öyle bir
şapkam var ve bu çalışmalarda Ama
görüyorsun ki
stk'ların da sorunları var
üye almakta veya doğru üyeyi almakta
kaynak yaratmakta
üyeleri çalışmaya motive etmekte Burada
da yaratıcı olmanız gerekiyor Biz mesela
kinglerden mikrokratik kadınları ve
sonrasında da
için nasıl bir kaynak yaratırız nasıl
bir şey yapabiliriz diye
düşündüğümüzde işte iş kadınları Ev
Kadınları
hekimler avukatlar Biz bir koro kurduk
ve şarkı türkü söyleyerek çok ciddi para
topladık öyle bir şey ki kulakları
çınlasın isim vermeyeyim şimdi ilk
çalışmalarına başladığımızda bir
sanayici arkadaşı aradım ya dedim böyle
böyle dedim bizim böyle bir şeyimiz var
sende bir bağışta bulunmak ister misin
bulunayım dedi sonrasında biz bu şarkı
türkü o Gala yemeğine davet ettik
şarkıları söyledik indim gittim yana
nasıl dedim beğendim ya abla dedi saniye
çıkıp şarkı söyleyeceğini bilseydim daha
çok para verirdim dedi
Talas sanatında da şöyle bir şey yaptık
Yani biliyorsunuz farklı
kaynaklar var işte Avrupa Birliği hibe
projeleri var büyük elçiliklerin böyle
fonları var
büyükelçiliğinin bir kültür çağrısına
proje yazdık ve o projeyi de kazandık
geçen sene bu kitabımız yayınlandı bir
kazanda 3 kepçe yani Kazan Anadolu
Kültürü 3 kepçede Rum Ermeni ve Türk
yemeklerini
anlatmak istedik tabii biz burada tar
Yemek tariflerini topladık yemek
tariflerine de toplarken aynı zamanda
baktık ki insanların bu yemeklerle
ilgili anıları da var bu sefer anıları
da koyduk yemeklerle ilgili ve biz bu
kitabın Türkçe İngilizce olarak çıkardık
iddia ediyorum yöremizdeki Türkçe
İngilizce çıkan ilk yemek kitabı bizim
kesin
aynı zamanda Ben Talas maharetli Eller
kadın Kooperatifinde ortağıyım hemen
buradan da bir duyurusunu yapayım her
pazar birinci ve üçüncü günü de
pazarımız oluyor harman meydanında
kadınlar kadınları imkan verilmesi lazım
Herkes bir şey üretiyor ama satışa
geldiği vakit pazarlanmaya geldiği
vakitte biz bu kadınlara yardım etmemiz
gerekiyor o yüzden bu kooperatifte
2021'de kurduk Sanırsam İki senedir
böyle yürüyor
ben aynı zamanda bir eğitim gönüllüsüyüm
ve Türk eğitim Vakfında da yürütme
kurulumdayım Bir de öyle bir şapkam var
yani Çoluk çocuk Kötü giden bir evlilik
Borç harç başınıza gelecek Erken
kayıplar daha farklı Türlü Şeyler sizi
kesinlikle
hayattan çalışmaktan alıkoymasın bunlar
size
motivasyon versin
[Alkış]
bir de şunu fark ettim esasında kadınlar
ama evli kadınlar her gün mikro bazda
bizim sanayide Makro bazda yaptığımız
şeyleri yapıyorum mesela ne kadın da
evde üretiyor işte mantı yapıyor Yemek
yapıyor Ben de sandalye üretiyorum
kadın da evde bir Stok kontrolü yapıyor
işte yeteri kadar unum varmış Şekerim
var mı Ne bileyim kıymam var mı Yumurtam
var mı Ben de burada yeteri kadar
metalin süngerim kumaşım Neyin var mı
diye kontrol yapıyorum mesela first in
first Up diye bir şey var hani farklı Bu
stok şeylerinde tabirlerinde ilk giren
ilk çıkan bütün kadınlar eminim
eski limanları çıkarır yenileme
Biz de sanayide emin olun aynısını
yapıyoruz veya mesela
birçok süreci kadınlar paralel bir
şekilde yapabiliyor işte önce çamaşır
makinesine çamaşırları atıyor Ondan
sonra atıyorum yemeye girişiyor ve böyle
ne yapıyor iş plana çıkarıyor iş
süreçlerini planlıyor Biz de sanayide
çok benzerini yapıyoruz o yüzden böyle
Keşke biraz Gülse Birsel gibi böyle
esprili bir yazı tarzım olsa da ben bunu
da kitaplaştırabilsem diyorum
son olarak
son olarak Özellikle buradaki gençlere
bir tavsiyede bulunmak istiyorum
bir yerde okumuştum sadece sözlükte
başarı kelimesi çalışmaktan önce gelir
bakın başarı Yani tabii Biz eskiden
sözlük açıyorduk şimdi herkes Google
bakıyor ama başarı önce sadece sözlükte
var önce çalışmak gerekiyor ve bunu
İngilizce'de de Fransızcada da aynısı
bir Almanya'da önce çalışmak geliyor ama
biliyorsunuz hep çalışırız biz Alman
olarak
şimdi Umarım bu anlattıklarımdan
sıkılmamışsınızdır Umarım vermek
istediğim mesajı size vermişimdir
ve çalışma azmanızı yaşama azminizi en
önemlisi hiçbir şey kısıtlamasın beni
dinlediğiniz için çok teşekkür ederim
[Alkış]